let's talk about solutions so-called
to the gun violence problem i'm gonna
play a clip for you here
of the last uh roughly 24 hours of fox
news and the roughly 50 solutions that
they have proposed to the issue of gun
violence it might not come as a surprise
that none of the solutions relate to gun
safety
okay
uh
let's just take a listen and see if you
can find the trend here i'll give you a
hint it's none of these things have to
do with guns unless you mean giving more
people guns i advocate always for an
armed security guard armed school safety
officer armed
deputy arming teachers potentially arm
and prepare and train teachers and other
administrators armed school staffers
bring in policemen training
the students themselves retired military
retired law enforcement we can offer
them tax breaks if you give law
enforcement the opportunity to impose
martial law we can guarantee safety and
security securing that perimeter kind of
providing kind of a ring of steel you
have the fences you have the main
administration building and then you
have wide gaps on either side the
fencing's not very high where the doors
locked bulletproof glass all of these
shootings have happened at the same time
that we see religion
and christian values and
that's another one it's got the problem
isn't guns the problem is lack of god
judeo-christian values declining anybody
who decides that they want to do
something like this should immediately
know
that attacking a school is a death
sentence for them kids are afraid of
being the school snitch we have to stop
letting these schools be gun-free zones
people need to put their phones down and
get to know the person next to them we
have spent billions of dollars on
covet-related measures for our schools
let's take some of that money and divert
it over to hardening these soft targets
a lot of these private schools they take
security way more serious parents take
your children to church this anti-police
narrative is forcing people not to call
police a series of interlocking doors at
the school entrance that are triggered
by the way how absurd people are not
calling the police the police were on
the scene 40 to 60 minutes while the
shooter was rampaging in the classroom a
tripwire and it traps the shooter like a
rat god is the answer to that there's a
moral rot going on that we all need to
dig in and try to address i vote for
decreasing social media exposure we need
to start focusing on mental health tell
us why you think it's important to pray
in a moment like this it calls for faith
and prayer why is it that schools are
protected in the same way that airports
there are some people who don't want a
police officers in schools with guns
because other people are triggered
assault rifle
triggering is the people being triggered
is the problem it's body armor a
notification system to let everybody in
the school know what's happening
to a point of entry i don't like talking
about this stuff as it happens because i
don't think it contributes anything
positive parents should be held
accountable for raising their children
properly holistic blankets we just don't
have the resources to get law
enforcement there quickly how about an
executive order for these mental health
facilities we have to start rebuilding
this country and returning to god i i
arm myself everywhere i legally can it's
up to you to protect yourself
wow
oh boy guys that we're we are screwed as
a country dear god um by the way you
know a couple of those suggestions
ballistic blankets and armor-plated
backpacks for kids
the very same people who for two years
have been saying oh if you make kids
wear masks in schools the psychological
effect of that is going to destroy them
now they're saying
let's send children to school with
ballistic blankets and bulletproof
backpacks to be taught by armed teachers
in a school surrounded by tripwire with
prison-like fences and airport security
come on guys
this is this is absolutely absurd
and i want to focus next on this issue
of doors now they're blaming doors one
of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video